el día más caluroso del año en promedio
en santiago de chile- es enero 7 cuando
la media de la temperatura máxima es 29
grados centígrados el día más frío del
año tiene una media de temperatura
máxima de 14 grados centígrados use una
función trigonométricas para modelar la
temperatura en santiago de chile
usando 365 días como la duración de un
año recuerda que en enero 7 es verano en
santiago cuántos días después del 7 de
enero es el primer día de primavera
cuando la temperatura alcanza 20 grados
centígrados hagamos este problema en dos
partes en la primera parte
estableceremos una función
trigonométricas para modelar la
temperatura en santiago en esta
tendremos la temperatura en función de
los días donde los días son los días
transcurridos después de enero 7 una vez
que tengamos esa función podremos
contestar la parte esencial del problema
la pregunta cuántos días después del 7
de enero es el primer día de primavera
cuando la temperatura alcanza 20 grados
centígrados empecemos entonces
construyendo una gráfica a partir de la
cual nos va
evidente porque están sugiriendo una
función trigonométricas para modelar
esto estamos hablando de variaciones
estacionales de temperatura son cíclicas
aumenta disminuye aumenta de hecho si
gráfica la temperatura promedio para
cualquier ciudad a lo largo del año vas
a obtener una función trigonométricas
así es que hagamos que este eje
horizontal represente el transcurrir del
tiempo en días con amoled son días
después de enero 7 así es que aquí
tendríamos el 7 de enero y el eje
vertical este es el eje horizontal el
eje vertical va a ser la temperatura en
grados centígrados así es que para el 7
de enero la temperatura máxima promedio
es 29 29 grados centígrados mientras que
para el día más frío la máxima promedio
es de 14 14 grados centígrados vamos a
ponerlo por aquí de tal manera que las
temperaturas máximas van a variar entre
este rango de valores la temperatura
máxima del día más caluroso que es 29
grados centígrados y el
promedio de temperatura máxima del día
más frío que es 14 grados centígrados
entonces recordamos que son temperaturas
medias máximas para santiago de chile- y
la razón por la cual es una función
trigonométricas es porque estamos
modelando un fenómeno cíclico si el 7 de
enero tienes una cierta temperatura 365
días después vas a tener la misma
temperatura si el 7 enero hay 29 grados
centígrados en promedio como temperatura
máxima 365 días después el 7 enero del
año siguiente se va a tener la misma
temperatura máxima de 29 grados
centígrados y el punto medio se va a
alcanzar a la mitad pues estamos usando
una función trigonométricas exactamente
a la mitad vamos a alcanzar el punto
medio
así es que nuestra función
trigonométricas se va a ver más o menos
como eso voy a hacer aquí en el punto
mínimo más o menos así y luego aquí en
la parte del primer valor máximo más o
menos así aquí tenemos nuestra función
trigonométricas y también aquí en el
segundo máximo
y el aquí está es la gráfica de un
periodo completo de la función
trigonométricas el periodo es de 365
días después de 365 días me encuentro en
el mismo punto del ciclo cuando ha
pasado un ciclo completo estoy en el
mismo día del año ahora ya que hemos
construido la gráfica lo que quiero
hacer es obtener el modelo la función
que vamos a denominar t mayúscula en
términos de d queremos una expresión
para la temperatura t en términos de los
días de hace una pausita t pensar en
esta función te recuerda es una función
trigonométricas supongo que ya lo
intentaste y te preguntaste bueno esto
parece una función se en una función
coseno cual debo de usar de hecho puedes
usar cualquiera de las dos pero yo
siempre prefiero usar la más fácil aquí
lo que podemos considerar es que si
estos fueran valores de ángulos cuál
sería la función trigonométricas que
corta el eje y en su valor máximo bien
coseno de cero es uno mientras que seno
de cero es cero así es que nos conviene
utilizar la función coseno vamos a usar
la función coseno así es que
temperatura de en función de los días de
va a ser igual a cierta amplitud que
vamos a calcular multiplicada por coseno
de algún argumento que va a incluir los
días y también tendremos que incluir
cierta traslación de la función veamos
como hacemos esto cuál sería la línea
media aquí la línea media se ubica justo
a la mitad entre el valor máximo y el
valor mínimo la podríamos visualizar más
o menos más o menos por aquí estaría la
línea media y cuál es este valor
calculamos el promedio entre 29 14 29 14
43 entre 2 este punto medio corresponde
a 21.5 grados centígrados la función
coseno le estamos trasladando entonces
21.5 unidades hacia arriba si fuera la
función coseno usual tendría su línea
media en el eje x pero esta función la
estamos trasladando en 21.5 esa es la
traslación ahora cuál es la amplitud la
amplitud es que tanto se aleja la
función de la línea media aquí estamos
punto 57.5 unidades arriba de la media y
aquí estamos 7.5 unidades abajo de la
línea media así es que nuestra amplitud
la mayor variación que hay con respecto
a la línea media es de 7.5 y ahora
veamos cuál es el argumento de la
función coseno aquí sabemos que va a ser
una función de de de los días y que
queremos bien como vemos en la gráfica
queremos que cuando hayan transcurrido
365 días
este argumento sea 2 pi así es que
cuando decía igual a 365 queremos que
esto sea igual a 2 pi es decir
multiplicamos de por 2 pi entre 365 y
quizá tú te acuerdas de las fórmulas a
mí siempre se me olvidan por eso siempre
trato de razonar las no sé aquella que
te dice que hay que dividir entre dos y
para obtener el periodo la función y
esas fórmulas que hay pero lo que
razonamos aquí fue después de un periodo
cuando de es igual a 365 quiero que todo
el argumento sea dos pi quiero haber
dado una vuelta completa al círculo
unitario así es que de es 365 multiplica
por doscientos trescientos sesenta y
cinco se cancelan los tres 165 y nos
queda tan solo dos y ahí está ya la
tenemos ya hemos hecho la primera parte
de este problema hemos conseguido
modelar la temperatura promedio máxima
en santiago de chile en función de los
días después del 7 de enero en el
siguiente vídeo contestaremos esta
segunda pregunta y te invito a que
pruebes encontrar la solución por tu
cuenta y te voy a dar una ayuda
asegúrate de tomar en cuenta que se
están refiriendo al primer día de
primavera